[Music]
our connection or part Okanagan the
excess infrastructure and transport
helps to ensure a high quality of life
in the Waimakariri district with 11,000
residents traveling to Christchurch for
work each day our inter-district
connections are critical to meeting the
expectations of commuters increased use
of public transport and alternative
commuting options will be required to
avoid increasing congestion we also need
to ensure our towns are well connected
by roads cycleways and public transport
to cater for our growing population and
that infrastructure keeps up with growth
we also need to think about emerging
transport technologies such as
autonomous and electric vehicles and the
potential digital connectivity has to
replace commuting our districts our
future Waimakariri 20:48 aims to improve
connectivity within our growing district
including the opportunities for walking
and cycling advocate for improvements in
public transport and rolling through and
from Christchurch integrate the future
urban growth areas into our existing
infrastructure
so what do you think let us know your
thoughts and find out more about the
district development strategy at
Waimakariri govt T thoughts NZ
[Music]
[Applause]